ya pas qu est ce le bon rôle que vous
attendiez banon a bien dit j'aime bien
me dire spontanément c'est très agréable
à faire c'est une émission de qualité
c'est intéressant tout ça mais je peux
pas dire non ce serait absurde de dire
c'est le rôle de ma vie c'est bien c'est
intéressant à faire cette dame un petit
peu coincé un petit peu coincé comme ça
qui est assistante de ce toubib jérôme
anger le vrai rôle c'est jérôme gérons
que superbe dedans d'ailleurs vous êtes
un peu jalouse là la seule maman là
maintenant j'arrive par rapport à ce
rôle cas jérôme anger parce que ça
aurait dû s'appeler l'assistante parce
qu'à ce moment là cd vous laisse à la
salle s agit staut ouais non ça me oui
c'était s'arrêter bien aussi bon fall
non mais c'est parce que d'un coup je
pensais pas que ça allait ça
m'intéressait parce que c'était
intéressant quand on m'en fous je fais
très peu de télé vraiment je suis une
fille de tes alger très peu de télé
angie bombe
oui tiens je sors ça se marrant c'est un
personnage assez drôle et je pensais pas
que ça allait avoir un tel impact bon
voila j'ai l'impression que vous allez
pas satisfaits par votre carrière
non non vous êtes passé à côté
alors je vais vous dire une chose j'ai
exactement la carrière que je mérite
plus sa serait ce parce que j'ai
toujours traîné la patte
je suis d'une paresse quand vous donnez
un coup de collier je donne j'aime ce
métier
bien sûr les choisis ta me vois tout ce
que je sais faire mon chez moi hier sur
une scène où écrire quelques lignes
donc je le fais mais en prenant des
grands âges de de repos de la vie la vie
de tout ce qui me passionne et qui ne
juge pas une folk il ya un type qui me
je voudrais être comme lui c'est
terzieff terzieff quand je vois lui lui
laurent ils bouffent du théâtre puisse
nourrit théâtre moi non
vous êtes quand même plutôt dans la
catégorie rigolote j'aime pas ce thème à
paris juste quand je vous ai glissé au
public ce règlement non je suis j'ai une
nature j'aime le rire j'aime la vie je
pense quand on aime la vie comme je
laime effectivement elle est faite de
plein d'éclats de rire elle fait plein
de calais le français est à fait correct
là c'est très joli veux vous dire à
poèmes
oui vous avez quand même été la femme de
maurice
oui c'est un oui il regrettait un seul
mari d'ailleurs comédien et on a fait de
la cdu grand souvenir parce que nous
avons fait moi j'ai eu une carrière très
très tardive et maurice tournait déjà
mais il faisait beaucoup de peinture et
moi aussi
moi je fais de la peinture sur tissu et
on a fait c'est un souvenir
extraordinaire on a fait une exposition
tous les deux mois de mai tissus peints
et lui de ces gens corps une très belle
toile de lui à ballainvilliers à la
campagne pourquoi dites-vous
derrière tardy on va très tardive
écouter j'avais trente trois ans j'avais
jamais mis les pieds sur une scène joue
les danseuses bon qui toutes les
comédiennes on dirait qu'ils ont voulu
être danseuse moi j'avais les jambes
trop courtes aura jamais une grande
danseuse et de jolis pieds a dit samedi
à mes pieds les chaussures est au bout
j'aime bien me chausser
bonjour n'était oui flett danseuses et
puis bon j'ai tu fais je suis né sur des
pointes à biarritz en espadrilles
j'étais automatiquement sur les pontons
à penser que ce sera une grande danseuse
ça veut rien dire mais piété comme ça y
est voilà puis après j'ai pris des cours
de théâtre et puis et puis je l aime ce
métier je l'aimais je laime points je
n'aime pas d'une manière démentiel parce
que je suis fasciné par tout ce qu'il ya
autour
dieu sait si on a des choses rêve jamais
le temps jamais jamais le temps
coline serreau vous a à donner aux très
beaux rôles dont la cruelle et étant
nommé ce tableau le rôle d'une femme de
50 ans qui décide tout d'un coup devant
sa famille de lire je pars c'est le
suzannois j'ai rencontré quelqu'un je
vous plaque je vous ai élevé
tous avaient jeumont plaques oui mais
c'est drôle parce que les femmes
beaucoup de femmes se souviennent de ce
run beaucoup de gens me parlent de la
crise parce que je pense que toutes les
femmes se sont identifiés à cette somme
qui avait merveilleusement élever ses
enfants qu'il ya ceux qui en avaient ras
le bol elle les aimait mais on peut leur
dire allez circulez vous avez tout mon
coeur vous êtes toute ma tendresse ou
pour un jour qu'on tire mais maintenant
ça va
et vous pourriez également joué la
tragédie ah ben je commence à la
tragédie n'a pas le temps mais je
voudrais tout les tirades hermione on a
entre max bien sûr ah ben je suis une
dramatique quand vous regardez où elle
pas tellement envie de rire un bon j'ai
un visage c'est vrai un petit peu taillé
un peu faible quand même une gueule de
tragédienne plus qu'une non c'est parce
que je suis une comédienne et je pense
quand même
pas faire de fausse mardi six cordes
être une bonne comédienne que je peux
aussi faire rire voilà la comédie
française
ça n'aurait pas l'horreur à non non non
non syrienne comme je le disais
peut-être la tentation l'ambition non
pas du tout non non non non non non la
prison a pour moi ce serait la prison ah
oui peut-être que j'exagère un peu
triste pour eux là bas mais ils sont
contents parce que j'adore robbery
rejeté un grand ami j'adore robert mais
en vérité c'était somptueux quand
j'allais le voir là bas dans sa loge de
sa wii pour ces gens là mais pas pour
moi pour moi maria c'est une prison
[Musique]